hi my name is Eric hostel I'm the
creator of advent of code why don't we
begin here before we get started a quick
show of hands how many people have
actually heard of advent of code before
we like actually oh good ok that's
that's important that's a probably a
prerequisite for parts of this talk how
many people have solved at least one
puzzle though all right still like the
same number of hands how many people
have completed an entire year
how many people have completed all of
the years one there's only a couple
hundred people in the world that have
completed all of the years well done all
right well yeah so my name is Eric wass
tool and this is Advent of code behind
the scenes who let this guy in stage
anyway so I used to make large-scale web
applications for ISPs but now I work on
infrastructure for an auction system
both of these companies are in Buffalo
where I live these are my day jobs on
the side I also run programming
challenges like advent of code I also
make tools for games
these are EVE Online League of Legends
minecraft and World of Warcraft in that
order I also make fun of programming
languages if you've ever been to these
websites this is also me just being
snarky instead of teaching people stuff
I also make lots lots of other random
things but we're not here to talk about
those weird to talk about atom to code
so what's Advent of code let's rewind a
little here's a question what if you are
here sorry let me zoom in a little bit
there sorry
what if you are here at this tiny cafe
in Salem Massachusetts hanging out
because you're there with some friends
that like Halloween and they wanted to
come and see the place where Halloween
and celebrate whatever and all you have
is a pen a few napkins a few weeks until
Christmas a random memory of advent
calendars and a passion for programming
puzzles and helping people learn to
become better programmers the answer
advent of code which is a combination of
advent calendars and programming puzzles
so advent calendars yeah so you
depending on
how you celebrate Christmas or whether
you celebrate Christmas you may have
seen these an advent calendar is
typically a little like cardboard box or
sometimes something can hang stuff on or
whatever that every day for the season
of Advent which varies by how you define
it but an advent of code we use the
first 25 days
you basically countdown until Christmas
opening up a little door and getting out
a little chocolate or a toy or you know
whatever a programming puzzle may be
there's very traditional gift into
advent calendars this one is mine
when I was growing up you take out the
little ornaments you just hang them on
the trees don't really get anything but
it's usable it's nice right
at Advan of code they look like this
where every line is a door that you can
click on and you can open it up and get
a puzzler sometimes they look like this
or sometimes they look like this so
where's the programming puzzles in here
well they're down here every day one of
these lines lights up and you can click
on it and when you do you get a puzzle
and the puzzle has some kind of goofy
story about Santa and elves and rescuing
Christmas and all of these things that
go on and eventually you get down to the
part where it actually explains to you
what you're programming today
and in this one this is the the first
one of last year it says add up all the
numbers in the file okay
well that's that's all right that's fine
what's where's the file okay there it is
get your input the puzzle and puts the
same for Part one and Part two spoilers
and then you finally get the answer and
you add them all up and you put them in
this box and hit submit and you get a
gold star and then you move on to part
two which takes the same input but makes
you do something different with it and
hopefully something that forces you to
rethink how you approach the problem or
maybe it was something that tried to
verify that you were on the right track
for solving the puzzle or something I'm
getting into how I designed that stuff
in a second but part two of this one was
you have to keep going through the list
adding up the numbers over and over and
over because there's pluses and minuses
and it asks what number do you reach
like what what total vut do you reach
twice in a row or not twice in a row
twice at all ever and it takes about a
hundred loops and you go through and you
finally get a second value and once you
fill in that one you get two stars and
then the calendar starts to do something
and as you answer more puzzles the
calendar fills up more and more
until eventually you have a full
calendar and there's a coffee mug
floating in space for reasons that are
spoilers and you'll have to solve the
puzzle to find out
so it's 2015 and you just built a bunch
of programming puzzles where should we
host this thing programming puzzles
probably won't be that popular let's do
some some capacity planning many of you
probably have your engineers have to do
some capacity planning at your job of
some sort I have to figure out how big
the server should be the host of right
programming puzzles won't probably
probably won't be that popular but I
have a few friends that might like it ok
and I've released silly programming
things like this before so I have a
rough idea you know they might have a
few friends that like it 50 people 50
people seems like a pretty safe guess
friends and friends of friends and it's
programming puzzles and you know it's
kind of a niche thing mmm but I learned
at work that we should have good margins
on our estimates 70 wide margin right
all right good so a small personal web
server will cover it just fine there'll
be no issues I've got a server that's
running someplace that will be able to
handle the traffic point that point the
domain name added hosted there it'll be
easy
so it's November 30th 2015 now it's
almost December 1st it's time to
published right publicize the site to
the world and tell everybody to go to it
and do whatever there is nobody's heard
of this thing before so I release my
secret project and it gets 27 retweets
which is perfect that's within margins
good
okay so capacity planning is fine 27
retweets is fine so here's a graph of
the number of users that have signed up
starting when I announced it and open
the site up until midnight before the
first puzzle unlocks so there are 70
users there's 81 users looks like we're
well within estimate that seems
completely completely reasonable nothing
bad will happen
foreshadowing uh then the puzzle
unlocked and the graph does this if
you're if you're not a technical career
path you you may not know the technical
term for this shape of a graph which is
hope
no no no no no 12 hours later there's my
estimate and the graph is just gone it's
just left let me zoom out a little bit
that's where it what it did this is a
bad shape for your graph to have that's
my estimate that's 4,000 people so okay
I mean capacity planning right we should
consider how how this is going so far
take a step back we estimated 70 people
we have 4,000 12 hours into the event
it's a 25 day long event that's not
great we're off by five thousand six
hundred percent the small server is very
sad that's also the technical term for
that
so you're bad at traffic estimation now
what so you've got this project that you
didn't expect to be popular this parts
interactive by the way you have this
project that you were expecting to be
popular and or that you weren't
expecting popular and it's just like
small server running you know can't keep
up with this traffic the the CPU levels
are high the memory usage is high the
disk the disk i/o is high like this is
not going to keep up with this kind of
growth curve now what what do you do
scaling scaling what it's one server I
don't have I don't have time to like
build out a infrastructure somewhere
what do you do caching maybe except that
every user has different content
different website different internet did
anybody say turn off the minecraft
server because that got way more
capacity turns out that was the problem
at least part of the problem because
then the numbers kept growing and we had
to do not item 2 which is don't create a
new process to handle every single
request no hang on what why why what is
that so CGI is kind of an old way to run
things but it's an easy way to prototype
build stuff the way CGI works is you
have I process a typical UNIX POSIX
process typical processes have some kind
of input environment variables and
standard in and that sort of stuff they
produce some kind of an output a
standard output standard error they in
in CGI they are mapped to the headers in
the request body coming in and the HTTP
response and the logs going out pretty
simple easy to build stuff eat easy to
produce
stuff sometimes it might also talk to
database files API calls things like
that but in general when you're running
a process in CGI you have these kinds of
inputs and outputs and the problem is
that while this is simple this happens
for every request you get which for 70
users is no problem but for 4,000 users
is very very very bad when you get rid
of that overhead by switching to
emergency switch fast cgi panic mode
that was a horrifying day it was much
much better fast cgi basically just
mimics cgi but doesn't actually restart
the process it just starts keeps feeding
at new inputs and it barely handled it
but it did work so 24 hours sense unlock
the graph continues to look like this
that's my estimate there's 9,000 people
so hold on a second where did all these
people come from like what's going on
does anybody see the flaw in my
reasoning you may notice that this part
of highlighted is recursive so this
happened because social media is a weird
place and all of a sudden everyone's
friends friends friends friends were
talking about it to their friends who
were talking about it to their friends
this Scrolls for a while 48 hours after
unlock there's my estimate that's 15,000
people let's fast forward a little bit
that's what the curve looked like at the
end of year one that's 52,000 people by
the by the end of the first year at
which point people were using the site
significantly less and we did the
actually correct capacity planning thing
which was to just move to AWS completely
which has been serving us very well
because if we'd more people you go to
the site I could just click buy more
servers until it stops breaking like a
real business right today we have
250,000 people and it's still growing
which is fine because I can click buy
more service a couple more times so why
do people do Advan of code what's going
on a lot of people do them as practice
problems either because they want to get
better at a language that they've
already been using or there's some new
language that they want to learn because
it sounds fun or because their job is
wiring them to do some new project that
has rates something like that but to
basically hone their skills on some kind
of a language or or on problem solving
or on like algorithm design or data
structures or in general right that sort
of stuff but a lot of people also do it
for interview preparation there are a
lot of companies that ask questions like
advent of code puzzles in their
interviews and people will use advent of
code for interview prep for that I'll
talk more on that in in a bit actually
there are some companies that do it a
sort of a company corporate training
sort of event thing where during
December they'll take a Friday and and
anybody that wants to go into a
conference room and work together on
these puzzles together like Friday
afternoon instead of doing their normal
job because that company is good and
thinks that learning is fun which it is
some people do it as a speed contest I
don't recommend this but there is a
leaderboard that tells you if you were
fast you weren't don't try it's not a
good idea the people that get on the
leaderboard are competitive programmers
that do this year-round and just like
this is just all they do all the time
they know all of the tricks they they
take all of the shortcuts they do not
build good like good maintainable code
like they're hacking together the first
thing that'll work they they already
have an implementation of highly
optimized a-star using a priority heap
on they're like like ready open enough
in a window like you're not gonna go
faster than that it's not it's not a
good idea and it's not fun I don't I
don't recommend but a lot of people
enjoy doing that more power to them
and also challenging their friends so if
you've gone to the subreddit which is a
very encouraging group it's kind of neat
I'll talk more about the community in a
bit a lot of people there will say hey
this puzzle was neat but I can think of
a way to make it significantly harder
can anybody solve my much much harder
version and some people can and it's
super fun and some people are like what
do you what and then they read the
solutions of what that's fun too and
then hopefully somebody comes along and
explains that everybody learned
something new that day so who are all
these people that are doing advent of
code
everybody primarily english-speaking
countries obviously but like I get
traffic from most countries like
significant traffic here's the United
States
New York is where I live Buffalo and
blaming California because when the
puzzles unlock at midnight in New York
it's only 9 p.m. in California which
means that they can actually still be
awake to do them
here's Europe where you guys have to
wake up at 5 a.m. and 6 a.m. and I'm
only a little sorry some people use it
as part of their morning routine though
this is somebody literally doing advent
of code while in the shower getting
ready for work and I get a lot of
comments about this both positive and
negative I get some people saying you
know waking up at 5:00 a.m. every day
it's not easy there's there's no way
that I can get up at that time I just
get up in my normal time and then I do
it during my lunch or whatever you know
and then there's a whole other group of
people that are say that that say
something like I have never been able to
wake up early as reliably as I can
December 1st through 25th because of
these pleasantly great that's cool there
are a bunch of people actually even in
Europe who stream the moment it comes
out at 5:00 or 6:00 a.m. like still in
their pajamas like like well done like
half awake like barely have their coffee
they're like what is this problem oh
it's alright I hang on let me just drink
17 coffees and I'll do like right on
stream like cool who are all these
people their programmers their
programmers of every type here's a bunch
of languages of all different
disciplines and and styles if you if you
look just on github for these you can
see 23,000 repositories of any language
you can imagine including some
repositories that have 25 different
languages in them which is alarming and
a little weird but super cool right like
go for it here's somebody that solved a
bunch of them one year using an FPGA an
FPGA is a circuit that you can tell to
be any circuit you want and so it's
basically solving it in like
configurable hardware I don't know
exactly how it works but it's super
super cool and they solved a bunch of
them by building a circuit and then
configuring their fpga to be that
circuit and then it would solve the
puzzle and it's really neat
you get companies that do it most big
companies have at least a small group
somewhere that's doing it there's London
Facebook posting all of their
visualization
on the on the the glass overlooking the
stairs just the people could see all
their cool stuff
here's a University I think in Poland
that everyday would translate the
puzzles so that during that day their
students could read in their native
language and then solve them and then
they would all post their solutions on
this on this buying column in their
Student Union so that people could see
all the stuff that they were working on
and work together on things that's super
neat non-programmers do it a lot here's
somebody doing I think this is day one
of 2016 in a graph paper which was
working out pretty well for this person
until they discovered that one of the
liked turn left right go this far turn
left right go this far distances was
like 600 and so they're getting out some
more graph papers they can go out the
rest they eventually got the right
answer though this is that actually they
just took them longer than the person
here on the couch who already is
finished but you know here's a guy on
reddit who is also a friend of mine
actually who does every year in Excel he
finishes about half of them which is
astounding because he's using Excel not
visual basic mind you literally just
cells into equations and like that's it
and he solves them and this is
incredible if you ever see him posting
his solutions just open up the
spreadsheet count the number of seconds
it takes for Excel to actually load the
spreadsheet and then try to figure out
what he's doing because it's madness
also on this note actually I was just
talking to a group where there's a
company where they're trying to get
their managers to get more into thinking
about puzzle solving and they're gonna
use advent of code to do it but most of
the program oast of the managers aren't
programmers so they're gonna tell
they're telling you managers like hey
just use Excel you can do it that way
and and there's a couple programmers
that are gonna be doing an excel with
them to try to show them like look if we
can do it in Excel so can you here's
here's somebody using Google sheets also
if you don't want to pay Microsoft you
can pay Google instead did solve puzzles
that way so here's this is a twenty
eighteen day six or seven I think it's
the one we have to have the parts for
the sleigh and you have to figure out
what order to assemble the parts in in
order to figure out how to build this
layer right and you're supposed to write
a program that figures out that it's a
directed graph and tries to find a
topological sort and does one there's
all these fancy words for the things you
have to do but you basically have to
figure out what order to do the parts in
right this
just took all of the data from the
puzzle plugged it into a Gantt chart
system and asked what the answer was and
that worked completely fine that's great
here's somebody that solved one of them
in Minecraft that the stone blocks here
are that are the data from the puzzle
and it's actually going through and
reading the data and doing the
calculations in mine it's not a good
idea but you can do it so let's talk
about let's talk about puzzle design a
little bit so I build a lot of puzzles
when when I'm ready for this year which
I am almost I will have designed 250
puzzles which is a lot of puzzles and
there are some things that I need to do
as part of the advent of code format
when I'm making a puzzle but there are
some things that I've taken away from it
and just used as good ideas in general
when designing a puzzle or anything
that's even puzzle shaped a lot of
corporate trainings or even just like
complicated documentation with examples
of like how to use a feature in some
library or maintaining or something like
that all how kind of this similar format
of like here's how to explain like how
this thing works how to use it here's
some examples of how it functions here's
places it might go wrong and explaining
that sort of stuff has to happen
regardless of whether you're doing a
corporate training or at an open source
library or making a puzzle on the
internet for a bunt for 50 of your
friends right so some of the things are
avoiding ambiguity which which sounds
obvious but it's a little bit more
difficult especially because I've got
users from all around the world many of
whom English's in their first language
so looking out for things like confusing
sentence structure or multiple
interpretations of a sentence it's
really easy especially in English
because English is awful to build a
sentence that just like doesn't make any
sense so that could be like read in two
different ways or you can't tell what
word is supposed to relate and paying
attention to that because I know what
the puzzle is supposed to say but you
don't and so when I read the sentence I
always read it the right way because I
wrote it but if you read it you might
read it a different way which is why you
need to have other people test the
puzzle that's really important or to
read the sentence that you wrote because
you have assumptions that they don't or
just multiple interpretations of what
you've written if something could mean
like if a word could mean two different
things but you don't realize it because
you're only thinking about the one
definition
avoiding expectations about sight
information this is a good one also for
interview problems if you design
interview problems expectations of
outside information can make it very
very hard for somebody to solve your
problem if you assume that the user has
taken a data structures course and
understands what a hash is or
understands what a what what a red-black
tree is or understands what a priority
heap is or whatever right or if they
taken they may not take it any CS course
at all depending on the material a lot
of people that do advent of code aren't
programmers they want to be programmers
and so they're saying all right I'm
gonna learn this language my friend gave
me in this IDE my friend installed and
I'm gonna start typing things into this
box until I get the answer according to
this website that's a common use case
and it's not a you know it's not a
common group of users but they do exist
and making sure that they that they're
also covered is important because it's
an important thing in helping people
learn to program right so they may not
have taken a CS course at all they may
not know what a conditional is they may
not know what it means to loop over
something they might not may not know
what an index is right and so trying to
either use those words and define them
on the spot or use a different word that
means the same thing like maybe instead
of index you say position or something
like that or at the very least linking
to an article someplace that explains it
B if you think the number of users that
might not know it is very low or
something right but avoiding the
expectations of outside information or
another one that's really tricky the
user might not have the same domain
knowledge as you so if you're asking
about slay building and you actually use
words that are part of like the industry
of building slaves which I am not so I
didn't big but like you could imagine
like if all you know attach this thing
to this thing in this slot whatever like
you can't that none of those words mean
anything to anybody unless you're in
that industry so if you're in an
industry that does some particular thing
like you're building cars or something
and your interview questions assume the
listener understands what some random
word and for a car part is that they
definitely don't but you forget that
because you're in the industry already
it's really easy to build a problem that
literally no one can answer but you
because you use terminology that doesn't
exist it's also really common in the
space industry everything in the space
industry is exactly three-letter acronym
long every single term for anything
it's extremely confusing avoid requiring
the user to make assumptions so I I used
to repeat myself a lot less in early
puzzles because this wasn't really
obvious to me yet but as I built more
and more puzzles it occurred to me that
for every sentence there is a user
that's skipped only that sentence just
because they were skimming or glossing
over or whatever they there jumped down
a line for whatever reason and they
didn't realize that that sentence was
important so if something is critical
try to either state it more than once in
a different way or or imply that it's
true someplace else in the documents
that they say wait I don't remember I
don't remember reading this let me go
back and find her like but entire thing
together it's that they can't have like
one bit of information that they that
they missed and don't realize they
missed and also having other people
actually look at and test the puzzle
they I have a team of beta testers
they're excellent they read through the
puzzle they tell me I'm dumb all the
time and then I go and fix the problems
until they stop telling me I'm dumb and
then everybody online you know still
finds problems with it but at least
we've caught most of the big ones right
but having other people look at it so
that the assumptions that I'm making
aren't intrinsic to the puzzle and and
all of the information that you need to
solve it is still in there is it turns
out really important so how do you make
an advent of code puzzles so once you've
done all of that the the properties of
an advent of code puzzle includes some
additional constraints one of them is
there has to be an exact exactly one
correct answer for every input the way
the white website works is you get an
input file and there are lots and lots
of input files but every single one of
them has exactly one correct answer and
all of the answers are different and
none of the answers are too close to
each other because that might mean that
an off by one error means that you're
getting somebody else's answer and
that's not good like so there's all of
these constraints around that it has to
work in any language or at least any
reasonable language so anything but PHP
and you are just getting an answer from
this user you're not running their code
which means that you can't you you can't
measure the performance of their code
because I don't want to post the
infrastructure to do that I want to put
up with the security risks of doing that
right there are some websites that will
run your Rattler so I'm told I try to
avoid other puzzle sites just in case
but I'm told that there are sites that
you you give them your code instead of
your answer and they run your code and
then if it was too slow they tell you it
was too slow and I
can't really do that so instead I have
to design puzzles where if you do it
with an algorithm that's too slow it
would take three years to solve on any
computer and if you do it with the
algorithm that I intended for at least
for optimization problems right if you
do what the algorithm that was intended
you get it in about five seconds or less
if you're using a compiled language and
that way I can still do like timing type
stuff and it's just if you don't do it
the way that was intended if it's a
problem that's looking for you to you
just never get the answer and it doesn't
matter lots of inputs I talked about
that two parts per puzzle so originally
excuse me originally I had two parts per
puzzle because I thought it would just
be an easy way for me to add on like a
little fun extra at the end of all of
the main puzzles all of the part ones
we're gonna be like the main puzzles and
then all the part twos were gonna be
like oh yeah what if you did this aw
that was cool okay
I just basically doubled my content
almost for free and it never went that
way at all what it ended up being was as
I started to build puzzles that were
even a little complicated it was
convenient to be able to use part one to
just make sure that the user was on the
right track so instead of having part
one be the puzzle part two is the puzzle
and part one just says like did you read
the input correctly like did you get all
the numbers in there currently do you
copy and paste it right or whatever
you're doing maybe you have to like run
a checksum over the values or maybe you
have to start implementing part of what
you're going to need in part two are you
on the right track because doing a jump
to a finished puzzle all in one go means
that you're not really sure where your
bug is if you do have a bug and you
either have to read through the
instructions completely again and try to
find where you misunderstood or mismatch
something or just you know you have a
typo someplace and it could be anywhere
whereas if it's if it's a checkpoint you
know that the first half is right and
you don't have to debug that part
hopefully again and then you just only
have to check you know half of your
remaining code so there's that but the
other thing that I'll try to do is for
puzzles where it makes sense and the
first question isn't that much of a jump
ask that question and then for part two
swipe the requirements out from under
you and you either built it in a way
that was planning for me to do that or
you didn't and spend another two hours
reworking your code which is is a good
way to simulate what really happens in
the real world we're a group of
Engineers all of a sudden get
information from their product manager
that says you know hey the
user really wants this button to be
configurable and what color it is and
you're like oh we didn't account for
that hang on a second we had a built-in
configuration system Naoto or whatever
you know also variety variety is really
important for a lot of reasons a lot of
people have different backgrounds a lot
of people have different interests a lot
of people have different skill levels in
different areas so making sure that
every puzzle is different or at least
that know that there aren't a bunch of
puzzles in the row that are all like the
same like a day after day after day
after day right like keeping things
interesting is important to make sure
that people don't burn out or that they
get stuck a bunch of times in a row
hopefully and you can't you can't
control it for everybody because
everybody has different sets of skills
but setting it up so that it stays
interesting or at least teaches
everybody something different every day
is is really really important and also
difficulty calibration sometimes if
there's an early puzzle that seems hard
or it seems weird sometimes it's just a
simpler version of a puzzle that I'm
gonna do later and I want to make sure
that everybody's done the simpler
version first that they have some of the
prerequisites that I'm about to assume
they have later on when they need that
stuff examples of that in the past were
like some of the path finding problems
in I think 2016 where there were some
earlier puzzles are just you know just
find the shortest path from here to here
okay like toss toss breadth-first search
and you're done and then the later
problems are like alright find some path
finding but you can't use breadth-first
search anymore because of some
constraints in the problem whatever
you're like okay well now what do you
know and you figure it out like that but
just introducing concepts whether it's a
weekday versus a weekend people tend to
have more time to do puzzles on the
weekends like on front Friday night and
Saturday night into the weekend so
making the more involved problems not
necessarily harder but just the ones
that have more stuff to figure out and
giving them given aiming to put those on
weekends where it's possible but it
isn't always variety for difficulty we
talked about that a little bit but it's
still really important because everybody
is good at different things you might be
really good at regular expressions but
you really might hate you know string
comparison I don't know and making sure
that all the puzzles require some
different set of skills helps with
difficulty because it prevents burnout
progression throughout the month yeah
they gradually get harder they build on
each other or whatever so scaling
that and making sure that goes well but
also having random puzzles that aren't
in that difficulty maybe you have an
early hard puzzle to prevent people that
are really waiting for some some juicier
puzzles maton preventing them from
having to wait until the end of the
month like okay here's a more
interesting one but it's still one
that's acceptable to intermediate
beginner programmers if they want to
work at it a little and maybe there's an
easier puzzle late in the month because
you know you've been working at hard
puzzles day after day after day oh it's
a it's an easy one this took me you know
twenty minutes I'm going to go back to
you know preparing for Christmas or
whatever you're doing and also thinking
about interpreted versus compiled
languages I talked about this a little
bit with like timing calibration but the
goal is that it regardless of the
language you're using if you if you come
up with the solution that I was hoping
you would come up with it should take up
most fifteen seconds to run on pretty
old hardware like accessible to anybody
regardless of the computer they have you
don't need a state of the art Mac or
whatever to solve the problem
efficiently but for the problems where
it's an optimization problem and I
actually am expecting you to implement
you know optimized a star on some subset
of the state space and you have to
figure out how to prune that correctly
and all of these things it's important
to design the puzzle in a way where even
if they're using a compiled language and
the speed-up they get from that it's not
enough to have a less optimal solution
to get them to get the answer in an in
reasonable amount of time like it still
needs to be a large enough gap that the
amount that you save from having a
compiled language is not enough to get
you the answer soon enough
and that takes a while to build to but
yeah there's a lot of things that go
into that so how do you actually make
one of these the the first step is
inspiration I get inspiration from a lot
of places I get inspiration from just
like random problems that I'm working on
at work or random things that I'm that
I'm building off to the side or side
projects that I'm working on or an open
source project that had to build a
function that just does kind of an
interesting thing or just random things
I see in the real world like oh that's a
neat you know giant mobile structure or
that's a cool sculpture there's a bunch
of tiles that are laid out in a neat way
you know and I'm stuff like that but
take inspiration for something try to
figure out how you could make a question
around it make a problem around it and
then research it make sure that it's not
just like something everybody has in a
standard library make sure that it's
actually something that's interesting
enough that people will care to work on
it
try to see what like house how studied
it's been already if it has been maybe
tweak it a little bit to at least get it
out of a is like it wasn't at one time
the online encyclopedia of integer
sequences where the one of the answers
was just in there
designing the puzzle so figuring out
like okay now that we are pretty sure
it's good let's actually construct like
a prototype or try to build something
out that just you know wait until it
feels like it's a decent puzzle build a
script that generates inputs literally
just run it and it spits out here's an
input file it might take you know a
couple hours to do but like here's a
good input file solve it just like
you'll have to because I need to get the
answers the same as you generate a whole
bunch of inputs using that process
generate and solve all the puzzles and
then write a story around it and the
story usually happens last usually the
like the variable names for example in
the input generator and the solvers are
not the same nouns that the story use is
the the the variable names in my stuff
because I haven't really even thought
about the puzzle yet because I'm gonna
change it a hundred times before I
actually write a story about it so the
the scripts are all like you know grid
and XY and whatever just like generic
terms when I actually get out to like
the the real story about it it's like
okay so what what what could I do that
would make a maze that the elves have to
have to explore like well it could be
the the first floor of a building
without a weird security system and okay
now instead of it being a grid it's it's
like hallways and conference rooms in a
building and those are the nouns we use
it in whatever right or every once in a
while because puzzles aren't the right
difficulty the beta testers get to it
and it turns out it's way too hard or
way too easy sometimes I have to move it
earlier or later in the month and all of
a sudden I have to rewrite all the pros
because none of it makes sense in the
story anymore and you go back and do it
so well it seems like this is the flow
it's not the flow is more like that just
you get there eventually but you go
round and round and round and figure it
out
it's it's a bunch of stuff so let's talk
about oh if that's clapping am i late
okay so let's talk about what what time
is it
six minutes alright so here's a couple
example puzzles I'll speed it up here's
a couple example problems this one is
how many square inches of fabric are
within two or more claims and it gives
you a list of like here all the claims
here's the coordinates of these things
and you can draw a thing like this and
then it says you know which one doesn't
overlap
with anything else it's there there it
is or you have ones that are like here's
a history of all of the times a guard
woke up and fall asleep and went on
shift
find the guard that has the most minutes
of sleep and all of all guards which one
is frequently asleep on the same minute
some people like to do data analysis and
so they'll build like giant diagrams and
graphs and things like this but other
people really enjoy just building
animations of the puzzle where every
once in a while the guard you know falls
asleep for a second and then wakes back
up and falls asleep again because
whatever great this is a puzzle I really
like where it just lists out all of the
places where there are walls and it's
trying to design a water reservoir where
there are walls and the water will come
in and flow down and some people like to
solve it by actually animating out the
solution which is super super cool I
love this where you can kind of see like
how the algorithm that they wrote
behaves in different situations and how
it fills in different parts and that
sort of thing here's one that tries to
define a maze by giving you a regular
expression that matches the solution to
the maze and it's designed in such a way
where if you try to actually run this as
a regular expression it will never
finish and the goal is to try to trick
somebody into building a very simple
regular expression like parser because
it's just letters and groups so it's not
that bad but if you try to just like
hand listening random strings until you
give it the answer it will never ever
ever finish but if you try to like step
through it and see what the steps are
and backtrack when something needs to be
backtracked you instead get this
visualization which actually steps
through the regex and figures out what
the maze is shaped like which is super
cool or here's one that asks what are
all of the squares or what squares are
closest to which points and you have to
try to find the the the region of
something I forget and then it says all
right now take all out all of the square
or all of the regions that are infinite
and you have to say well how do i how do
I know whether it's infinite like how do
I measure that how do I detect it what's
the situation here's a cool one that's a
cellular automata that ends up
generating these really cool spirals
just by random I was screwing around
with parameters for a Orford cellular
automata and I eventually found one
where the random initial conditions
typically produced just these cool
random paths
okay that has to be a puzzle now that's
required here's one where it gives you a
bunch of points and their initial
positions and velocities and it says
where do they collide if you just run
the simulation for a while and so here's
somebody that used a new plot to just
run all the points and to keep track of
where they are and all of a sudden they
all fly in and a bunch of them collide
and then a bunch of the rest of them
just spew off to infinity a lot of
people like to use the time it takes to
solve a puzzle as a metric for how hard
it is but I don't really like that
because like I said before the people
that are doing it right at midnight are
are all competitive programmers that do
this all the time and so the time that
it takes for a competitive programming
to do it is not gonna be the same amount
of time as the time it takes you to do
it the competitive programmers are used
to fancy data structures fancy
algorithms skimming the problems a whole
bunch whereas most programmers aren't
focusing on that stuff they're thinking
like how do I build a solution that can
handle problems of this category how
could I build some code that maybe I
could maintain or maybe just how can I
stumble through rust until the bar
checker stops yelling at me but you know
regardless of what it is your time isn't
gonna match these exactly but this does
show that people roughly spend about you
know less than an hour that at least the
speed programmer is solving all the
puzzles which is good and the ones that
are up there I'm sorry for it's it's
hard to calibrate difficulty it's very
difficult so let's talk about some
growing pains no wait let's talk about
some learning experiences they're the
same thing how do you prioritize tasks
I'm great at this this is my strategy
all right thing happens you handle the
thing go to one easy every one thing at
a time everything is taught pretty how
do you prioritize tasks if you have
250,000 users from all around the world
of all different backgrounds okay let's
see how that worked
thing happens great handle ooh thing but
while you're handling the things several
other things happened and when you try
to handle those things more things
happen and then you never sleep this is
bad so you actually have to take and
take a second to think about what's
going on actually stop to prioritize
things which I'm not used to but it's
really important obviously it's okay to
ask for help a lot of people struggle
with like being able to say out loud
like I am having problems and need help
with the thing that I'm struggling with
but that's an okay thing to say and you
should say it all the time because it's
acceptable and fine and you need help
and it's okay right better document
that users can ask you fewer questions
because they already have the answers
from somebody that somewhere that it's
written down have an incredibly
supportive community that helps itself
so the subreddit is full of people who I
don't know why but are all extremely
supportive and if you come to them with
an aunt with a question like hey this is
the code I wrote for this problem it's
getting the wrong answer this is my
input this is what I'm getting what's
going on and they never never do they
say oh you're dumb you have a typo here
they'll say things like try it with this
input what I like what does your program
do or like step through the logic of
your program when you give it one of
these or have you thought about what
happens in this situation just like try
to ease people through it which is
incredible and really great and
everybody's teaching each other and I'm
really thankful for it also automating
tasks and providing tools both
self-service and just for me so if a
user needs me to to do some action to
their account manually going to the
production database and typing in the
query that does that it's not a good
strategy surprisingly you should instead
build tools and have things just
automatically occur whenever possible
because that's one less thing that you
have to think about when things happen
you have to handle the thing and more
things happen as per steps one through
five also accessibility accessibility is
pretty important but accessibility
becomes more important when you have a
quarter million users looking at your
site following the so the accessibility
groups guidelines for things is really
really important carefully testing it
making sure that users of all different
backgrounds and all different
accessibility levels use your site and
give you feedback and taking that a
feedback very seriously is really really
important too it's just it's a critical
thing to think about a denial of service
tax a tax is fascinating first of all
why would you do s a programming puzzle
website it I don't know but we get them
fascinating fortunately AWS will let you
just say don't allow requests from any
of these IP ranges and I'll just block
like whole IP ranges for a while until
they stop because there's no other I
can't cope with it otherwise it's in a
way so I'll go through some frequently
asked questions quick yeah okay I'm
being told the very speed up so why do
they unlock at midnight or why don't you
make them a lock at a different time
every day because I have a job in a
family and that's when I can be awake i
watch the servers I make sure nothing's
wrong how long does it take to make 25
puzzles about four months of
all of my free time like literally while
I was here I was sitting in my hotel
room building puzzles like the past few
months I've just been like I can go go
to work I come home I build puzzles like
that just it takes forever can I send
you puzzle ideas please don't send me
puzzle ideas I have so many puzzle ideas
already I have a giant document with
hundreds of puzzle ideas if it's if it
looks like your email has a puzzle idea
in it I will reply back I did not read
your email it looks like a puzzle idea
if I'm if I made a mistake please let me
know but I don't want to deal with
copyright issues I don't know where you
got the stuff from I don't I can't
confirm that you didn't like grab it
from some other website you know I just
I don't want to deal with attribution
like it's it's okay I have lots of
puzzle ideas that's not something I'm
struggling with I don't it's it please
don't send me them why is this start
rejecting my answer probably because you
were one of the people that skipped a
sentence that was important today or
because you have some kind of a weird
bug in any case ask on the subreddit or
ask your friends or something people are
typically very helpful does the site
lock after getting a wrong answer or
occasionally why do I have to wait an
hour to submit my next guess the site
does lock after a long answer it locks
for 60 seconds if it thinks you're
spamming guess is it will make you wait
longer because don't spam guesses at the
website please if you see somebody on
the subreddit or on Twitter saying like
I can't believe I have to wait an hour
between guesses from they just submitted
a hundred guesses got them all wrong and
they're complaining now that they can't
submit more that's what that is how do
some people solve the puzzle so quickly
or are people cheating no they're just
very very fast they do this basically
all the time the way that they do it is
they open the input they look at what
they it that what the input looks like
because it the inputs all that matters
ultimately they guess it what the puzzle
is they read the last line of the prose
to see if their guess was right and if
it wasn't they've confirmed by just
looking back up a little bit then before
reading anything they build a solution
and then as they're building it they go
back through the prose like as they're
reading it somehow I don't know and then
they figure people post videos of
themselves doing this like live at
midnight and that's really what they do
and it's nuts they're not cheating
they're really solving it that fast is
today your birthday yes today is my
birthday thank you so much for asking
I'm gonna end with some quick stories
that I just really like because they're
ridiculous um so here's one that I like
as the non-participating mother of a
fourteen-year-old that got up at 4:50
a.m. I'm both massively impressed that
people do this and somewhat baffled that
nothing else has this effect I've been
reading here so I can make sense of the
conversation later in the day so this is
the mother of a 14 year old where during
the day the 14 year old just wants to
talk about this programming puzzle that
they've been working on and the mothers
like what words are you using and then
has to go to the subreddit to figure out
what they're even talking about so they
can actually have a conversation with
their 14 year old during December or
here's somebody that says that they help
them get a new job or I get some that
say like this help my significant other
like we went through these and help them
with interviewing or whatever there's a
bunch of these like this which is so
cool or my son and daughter are becoming
more interested in coding because of
your site which is fantastic or I got a
message once that said something like I
haven't had a good relationship with my
daughter but after she started seeing
the do Advan of code she's been asking
me to do it with her and and I've really
rebuilt that relationship but like it's
just completely ridiculous here's a
college course that used Advan of code
as a midterm and as the final in
conclusion engineering organization
should solve puzzles for fun in fact
everyone should solve puzzles for fun
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]